>>David Springer: Hi, everybody. My name is
Dave Springer. This is the "Beyond JavaScript"
session. We're going to talk about how to
bring your client code to the web.
So wouldn't it be awesome if you could take
client apps and serve them on the web as a
Web app? And that's what we're going to talk
about today. How we can do that.
A quick show of hands. How many people here
are client programmers versus web programmers?
So client programmers?
We've got -- that's -- okay. And then web
programmers, pretty much everybody else? So
that's about half and half.
Awesome. Good. So I got a little something
for everybody.
I am the tech lead of the Native Client SDK
group out in Boulder, Colorado, and we are
building the SDK on top of the Native Client
technology.
Today, we'll talk about the technology itself,
a quick overview. I'm not going to get -- do
like a really super deep dive into that. It's
just more of a, "Hey, this is what we can
do with it," this idea that we can merge these
two worlds of web programming and client programming,
and talk about how we can bring that native
code into the web.
I'm going to go through a couple use cases,
what Native Client is really good at. There's
this idea of a 90/10 application, which is
90% of your app is in web programming, 10%
of it in native code, versus the 10/90, which
is nearly all of it is in the native code.
You know, 10% is in the web and 90% is in
the native code.
And we're going to build an app right here
live on stage. Write code and compile it and
run it.
Okay. And then we'll go through Q&A.
So what is NaCl? We abbreviate everything,
you know, so Native Client is shortened to
"NaCl." This gives way to all kinds of bad
puns on salt and pepper and -- right? N-a-C-l?
Okay? Everybody got that?
[Laughter]
Good. All right. Good to keep up.
It is a sandboxing technology for the safe
execution data code. That means it's as safe
a JavaScript.
So today you're running your JavaScript in
a sandbox. We're providing another sandbox,
in addition to that one, to actually run your
native code. It is real CPU instructions.
It's machine code running on the native CPU.
It's not an interpreter.
You can do things in it, so we provide a kind
of a POSIX-like API, and I'll talk a little
bit more about that in a second. And we also
provide this pepper API. It goes with salt.
So it's the way that you talk to the browser.
And again, we'll get into that a little bit
more later.
It's a technology that helps you merge all
the benefits of web programming, so this -- you
know, when you program in the web, you write
it once and it runs everywhere. Doesn't matter
what platform it's running on. As long as
it has a browser, you can run a Web app. So
we merge that delivery promise with native
code.
So it's this idea that you write your native
code once, you build it, and serve it as a
Web app, and it runs on all platforms that
have a browser.
There are restrictions, okay? So the idea
is, we want everything to be as secure as
JavaScript, so if you were here in other sessions
-- for example, the Fireside Chat just before
this one -- we talked a lot about security.
So we're pretty uptight about it and we want
things to be safe, even though you're running
native code, which can potentially be quite
dangerous.
So how does this all work?
First of all, you take your source code, which
might be, say, C or C++, and you have to compile
it.
So we've provided specialized tool chains.
They're based on GCC. And we've modified them
slightly.
And what happens is you build for specific
CPU architectures. Obviously you are running
machine instructions, so that means you have
to compile for specific architectures. X86_32
versus X86_64 versus ARM, for example.
Once you've built and linked an executable
from your source code, then we do a static
analysis on it to make sure that your code
isn't doing something naughty. You know, so
we look at the -- we'll get into an example
of that in a second.
And that's a static analysis phase.
So if the code passes the static analysis
phase and it's okay, then it goes inside of
our sandbox to be run. And the sandbox actually
lives inside the browser.
Today we live inside Chrome.
So again, not an interpreter, but the sandbox
-- there are -- if you try to do nasty things
at run time, then the sandbox has to catch
those and halt the malicious code. So we don't
actually prevent malicious code from getting
into your browser, but we do our best to stop
it if it gets there and tries to do naughty
stuff.
So these are some of the restrictions that
I alluded to earlier.
You can't directly touch the file system of
the client computer. You can't do open, stat,
things like that.
You cannot fork off a process, obviously.
That would be bad.
You can't kill things.
If you -- there -- you can get a complete
list of all the disallowed system calls from
libnosis.a. That all comes from SDK if you
download it and at the end you'll see a link
of where to get that.
So how does it work?
You start with the browser, of course, which
has its own sandbox, and this is executing
your markup, your CSS, your JavaScript, et
cetera.
There is a bridge, the pepper API, and this
is how the browser -- the JavaScript in the
browser talks to the native code in the NaCl
sandbox.
And then there's the NaCl sandbox, which is
this run time that's actually running your
native code.
Okay. And as we go through all the examples,
you'll see this graphic and it will show when
I'm in the browser, when I'm on the pepper
bridge, when I'm in the NaCl code, and that
will make sense when you see that.
So how do we do things with our special tool
chain and validator?
So who can spot the evil code here? Hint:
There's at least four instructions in here
that are bad.
So for example, every memory access and control
transfer is potentially unsafe.
I mean, so things like this jump has to go
to a valid address. So this is all things
we can find out in -- during static analysis.
And this call, x86, for example, has a variable
length instruction word. So that means this
call can jump back into the middle of an instruction
and start executing bad stuff, right? So we
don't want to do that.
We don't allow that.
So what we do is, in this case of the call,
we say that we require a 32-byte aligned jump.
We also do things like we give you a fixed
amount of memory space to work in. You have
4 gigs, and you can't go outside of that.
You can make system calls, and we have this
idea of a trampoline.
So you're in your Native Client code that's
built with a special tool chain. It's all
validated. Let's say you want to call MMAP.
So the first thing that happens is that gets
bundled up with its parameters and pushed
through a trampoline into what we call the
trusted code, which is our sandbox, our NaCl
run time, that's built into the browser.
This goes through a dispatcher which looks
at all the parameters and makes sure that,
for example, you're MMAPing a legal amount
of memory and that your addresses that you're
trying to MMAP are okay, that they're within
range; that the descriptor you're trying to
map to is a valid descriptor that you got
from the untrusted libraries and so on.
Then if that's all okay, we turn that into
the actual real sys call that calls to the
operating system and does the MMAP.
That gets a return value which then goes into
the springboard, back to your untrusted code,
and off you go.
So if at any time during that chain of events
something goes wrong or it looks bad, your
code is halted.
And a halt, by the way, looks like a snap,
right? I mean, the thing just -- it just stops.
So we call this security model "defense in
depth." It's kind of akin to let's say you
bought something really valuable. You might
take that valuable thing and put it in a really
big safe, but you probably wouldn't take that
safe and just leave it in a vacant lot in
the Tenderloin.
What you would probably do is put the safe
in your basement, behind a locked door, which
has got an alarm system, and your front door
has a lock, maybe a big dog, and things like
that, right?
So that's the kind of approach we're taking
is: Let's try and get as many layers -- defensible
layers -- as we can get between the native
code and the OS.
And we do this by we have our own sandbox
that runs native code. It runs alongside of
the Chrome sandbox. So actually, malicious
code has to get out of two sandboxes in order
to try and do anything. That's pretty hard
to do. We do things like implement CORS, so
we -- our URL downloading/HTP request stuff
all works with that. We can blacklist CPUs.
Certain CPUs have instruction sets that are
known to be buggy, so we can -- it's pretty
rare nowadays, but you can do that.
You can blacklist NaCl modules. So this is
the same thing as blacklisting an URL, right?
Because it just -- as we'll see later, this
is just a Web app, so it's a URL and you can
blacklist those.
Native Client is an open source project, so
it's pretty -- we do security audits, we have
contests, we have public review of the code,
we have peer reviews. We're really, really
sensitive to the security issues and are trying
to get the attack surface as small as possible.
Okay. So why would you use Native Client?
First of all, choice of language is a big
deal, right? Let's say that you have a fairly
large investment in C++ or C, one of these
compiled languages for client code.
And we hear a lot of people saying they would
rather not translate all of that into JavaScript.
Especially if you have many hundreds of thousands
of lines of code. That can be quite a burden.
So now you can compile it with our tool chain
and with a -- what turns out often the case
is a fairly unchallenging porting effort you
can run the whole thing inside of Native Client.
Maybe you have some performance considerations
to think about.
Native Client does give you direct access
to the CPU and GPU.
You can take advantage of SIMD instructions,
so for example, if you have SSE3 in your app,
then you can hand-code that kind of assembly
language, as long as it is within our validator
rules, and most of them are.
You can take advantage of multi-core CPUs.
We implement the pthreads library, so you
can run multiple threads.
And actually in my example, I'll show what
happens when you do that and the kind of performance
improvement you can get by getting off the
main browser thread.
And again, if you're writing in a language
such as C or C++ where you can do things like
de-reference pointers and that's important
and it gives you the speed, then you can lay
out your data and you can do that. That's
not something that's very easy to do within
JavaScript.
And finally, this gives your client code the
browser as the delivery platform.
So it's no more that you have to opt into
a download or hard media. Basically, there
is a frictionless install. It's as if there's
no user install.
There's no opting into trusted code and -- you
know, and do you trust this site and so on
and so forth. There's none of that. You just
simply serve the NaCl module as part of your
website. That's it.
So it's the end of this stuff, right?
Plus, because it's a website, you're also
in the Chrome Web Store, which is a plus.
So let's talk a little bit about the 90/10
versus 10/90 style applications.
The 90/10 application, again, is just 90%
of your app is in web code, what we call -- it's
a Web app, in other words. It's markup, it's
CSS, JavaScript. 10% is Native Client.
Versus the other way around, which is that
very, very little of the code is actually
in the web and most of it is in the native
code.
So a 90/10 application, you know, is a web-centric
app and it needs some kind of an engine that
wants to take advantage of things like data
layout, multithreading, and so on and so forth.
It's kind of the situation where you want
to have a very low latency local server. You
can think of it that way.
An example might be crypto, right?
So you want to implement a DRM solution using
your specific crypto IP. And you can do this
now with Native Client because your crypto
technology, you can just down- -- you can
just literally stick it in the browser as
part of the web experience and ship your encrypted
data back and forth across the wire.
Another example might be a physics engine.
So you've got most of your game programmed
as a Web app, but you want to run a physics
engine and actually look at data in a certain
way. Again, a great example of this is a 90/10
use of NaCl.
A 10/90 application might be where you have
a very big investment already in C and C++
code, let's say, and you've implemented the
whole UI in the game experience, for example,
in that language.
So this is where you just need a very thin
shim, basically just the thinnest possible
delivery platform to connect into the browser,
but then actually deliver your entire game
as if it was one big client app. So that's
also possible to do. Great application of
Native Client.
Okay. Let's get down to building an app now.
We're going to build the Game of Life. It's
Conway's life simulation.
And we'll go through this in four stages.
So the first stage, we'll get started. And
for you client programmers out there, what
we're doing is building a website. We're not
building client apps anymore, as such. We're
building websites now.
So I'm going to go through kind of, you know,
those steps, because it's a little bit different,
it's a little bit different delivery mechanism
than perhaps what you're used to if you're
a client programmer. It's no more just, you
know, a dot exe that somebody runs. It's now
you have to go to a website and there's resources
that you serve.
And then we'll talk about how to integrate
with the browser. So this is getting the JavaScript
to talk to the native code.
And that gets a little tricky because the
interfaces are all asynchronous. If you're
used to the kind of programming where you
make a function call and then you get a return
value, that doesn't exist anymore.
So I'm going to get into that a little bit,
because it could -- it can be new to some.
Then we'll optimize by using multiple threads
and I'll show you how easy that is to do.
It's one of these things where I just make
some changes in the back-end code and everything
gets faster.
And then to wrap up, just show a couple of
the other interfaces that we have implemented.
Audio, HTP requests, things like that, and
we'll add, you know, sound files to this game.
It's a little gratuitous but, you know, it's
fun.
Okay. First stage, this is where we're going
to lay out the project. Again, we're building
a website, so there's more involved than just
build scripts and cc files for you client
programmers.
For you web programmers, this is going to
look absolutely boring and normal, except
for the fact that there are also dot cc files
and stuff that has to be run through the compiler,
so that's a little bit different. It's kind
of this merging of these two worlds.
Part of the SDK that we've built, we give
you some scripts to help you lay out these
projects, so it just kind of lays out some
simple files that get you started.
It gives you a build script that will run
the special tool chains. It gets you started
with a simple kind of dot cc file that has
the hooks to connect to the browser. And then
what we'll do is we'll --
Well, why don't I just do it. I'll just run
the script and make a simple project and you
can see what goes on, okay?
So here I am in the SDK, and if I go into
project templates, I can say initproject.py.
So I'll give it name. It is life2011.
Whoa. Okay.
And then directory equals examples.
Okay. So it just laid everything out for me.
Now, if I go up into here, exampleslife2011,
there's my simple template files.
We use scons for our build system because
it's kind of common among -- all you need
is Python. It doesn't require things like
segment on windows and so on and so forth,
so it just works.
So if I say "scons" right now and just build
it, here it is running the tool chain, and
it's generated some -- an inf file, which
I'll get into the details of that in a second.
It's produced the NaCl modules, a 32-bit one
here and a 64-bit one, for me, so now I have
my whole Native Client website. It's there.
It doesn't really do very much, but it's workable.
So what I'll do is run a little local Python
HTTP server and we're seal what that Web site
does right now. So, if I run that, and then
whip over to Chrome -- this is, by the way,
Chrome M11 stable. And Native Client is behind
a flag. So we can go into about flags and
see that Native Client is here. So it's something
you have to actively enable. Because it's
experimental still. So let me go to local
host. 5103/life2011. You can see I've done
this before. Okay. So there it is. I just
loaded my 90 module. And it's running. Promise.
It really is. It's not really doing anything,
but there it is. Done. So that was it. You
can see here the server was outputting that
it did some get requests and so on and so
forth.
So okay. So that was it. And, to go through
the kind of files, again, there's an HTML
template. There's a MFS is a manifest file.
We'll talk more about that. That's how you
actually glue the architecture specific nexes
into the browser. And that's how the Native
Client runtime knows which architecture to
pull in and run. Okay? And it makes the nexe
files and other stuff in there, some CSS I
have on an image.
So let's look at this actual code. I'm in
the browser now. You can see I've highlighted
the browser piece of the graphic there.
This is how we do it. Embed tag. It's that
simple. And we give it -- the source of the
file, this is JSON. That's the thing, the
NMF file is the thing that actually ties the
NaCl modules you built from native code into
the Native Client runtime. We tell it its
mime type is subtype NaCl. And this is just
some JavaScripty stuff that I have that makes
the embed tag expand to fill its tab. So kind
of faking out of full tab game.
Okay.
This is the nmf file. A piece of JSON. And
it says I want to map x86-64 architecture
to the specific nexe, x86 and so on. This
goes into the runtime. The runtime knows how
to figure out what kind of CPU architecture
you're actually running on. And it goes and
makes a request for the specific nexe it needs
to run on. You need to build a nexe for each
architecture you need to run on today, but
we do our best to make that all invisible
to the user. So in the life example we're
going to do some 2D graphics. This is akin
to using the tag. And this is on the pepper
bridge now. This isn't CSS code in the pepper
bridge. As an HTML5, you would use a canvas
tag. In pepper we say I want to make a new
2D context. And then I have a paint API, and
I can flush it. So it's fairly straightforward.
All right. Let's see what that looks like.
I have here a prebaked version of that Web
site. So here it is running. And that's Conway's
life simulation. And I can go and say enter
full screen mode. So that's that little piece
of JavaScript. All I did was tell the -- basically,
the 2D graphics context to expand itself to
fill the whole screen.
Okay. So that's pretty simple. Right?
I mean, it didn't really do anything except
just run the simulation. What's actually going
on under the hood there is the simulation
itself was all completely programmed in native
code. So that was all, basically, C++ code
running the simulation making a little automaton.
And the toolbar, the area where it was running
in, the thing along the bottom was all web
programming. That was all JavaScript and markup.
So let's get a little more interesting.
We're going to turn this into an actual web
application, kind of a little more of a game.
And what we'll do, for example, we'll go back
into the browser again now and start writing
in markup and JavaScript and do things like
write a little stamp editor. So those of you
familiar with Conway's life, you can give
it initial values to do things like lighter
guns and puffer trains and, you know, fish
and things like that.
So we can add a bunch of JavaScript to implement
this panel.
We'll add some buttons. So we can run it in,
you know, that random mode where it just gives
you a bunch of initial values randomly versus
actually stamping them down.
And then we can also change the automaton
rules.
Okay. So this is kind of, you know, for you
web programmers out there, this is just absolutely
everyday markup. Right?
Nothing special here. A bunch of JavaScript
to implement the panel. By the way, I -- in
this example, I'm using a lot of Google closure.
That's not necessary. I work for Google, so
it's easy. But Jquery, prototype. There's
many, many JavaScript libraries out there,
as you know.
So one of the things I want to do is actually
be able to click these stamps down and then
drag them along, right?
So I'm going to add that and process drag
events. I'm going to use closure for that,
because it's really simple. And we'll talk
about how to connect the fact that I've made
a mouse down to add a stamp, connect that
from the JavaScript through the C++. I'm going
to kind of get into that in a little detail.
Because that's asynchronous and maybe not
familiar to everybody.
We'll look at the pepper interface and the
post message style JavaScript interface that
we use. And then we'll actually work through
an example and add a clear button.
Okay. So, first of all, in the browser, I
want to add dragger. Simple. Goog.fx.dragger.
Done. It does the usual thing of look for
mouse move, mouse up, and turns them into
drag events. I have -- in my view controller
code, I have a listener that I took up to
those events and give it handlers. And in
the handler, all I do is I say, okay, I'm
going to handle the event. Stop propagating
it. And then I'm going to invoke the put stamp
it point method on my Native Client module.
And this is where we're going to get into
the bridging. So a little bit about how this
app is set up. The embed tag that you saw
earlier is actually represented by a JavaScript
object that I call a view controller. And
it owns the DOM element, which is the Native
Client module. So it appears to the browser
kind of like a JavaScript object that implements
certain things such as post message.
Okay. So here is the implementation of my
invoke method. Now this -- you can make this
as arbitrarily complex as you want. I just
build a simple colon separated string. You
could use JSON stringify for this. But then,
of course, you would have JSON going into
your C++ code. So, on the C++ side, you'll
see that later you would have to unroll all
the JSON. This is really, really simple for
me to go do. And how I get it in the NaCl
module is I call it on a DOM module. There's
a DOM element that modulates the NaCl module,
and off I go. Here's where the asynchronous
stuff happens, because this post message returns
immediately. There's no waiting. It just pushes
the message out to the NaCl module and returns
it and hopes it gets there. There is a way
to do closures and close that loop. I don't
have it in this example, but you can post
message back from the C++ to the browser.
So, if I had a closure here that did something
when it got to the C++ and got processed,
I could do that. This example doesn't have
it. A little quick word on how this works.
This is for the client guys who are used to
saying well, I call a method and it does something
and then returns. That doesn't happen any
more. What goes on now is that I say post
message from JavaScript. That puts that post
message command with its parameter and copies
it by value. So the entire contents of the
post message call get copied. So you can return
and start modifying it. But that copy is now
on the pepper queue, waiting to be processed
by the NaCl module. Then, later on, the NaCl
sandbox, which is running, picks that post
message up with its data and calls handle
message inside the pepper API. So the pepper
API is something that I have to implement.
It's a bunch of known call points inside my
C++ code. And I then am responsible for implementing
handle message, picking up that string and
parsing it and do whatever. We'll see how
that works.
So here I am on the pepper bridge implementing
handle message. So this is the other end of
the post message. So post message happened.
And the browser did copy the data. It put
it on the pepper queue and returned. The browser
is off and running again.
Now here I am in the NaCl module in the pepper
bridge, and I get a -- it's a variant. And
I say, well, if it's a string, then I'm going
to do the mirror in the C++ of invoke method.
So I just pull the string value off and call
my scripting bridge -- and this is something
that, actually, I wrote in the NaCl code.
So this is my own thing, again. It's the inverse
of what I did in the JavaScript. In the JavaScript
I built up a string of colon separated parameters.
This is C++ that takes the string apart and
builds, basically, a dictionary of the values.
And then here I just simply invoke a callback
in C++ with that parameter dictionary.
Okay. So we'll add a clear button. We'll kind
of go through this whole process. And this
is where I'm going to really write code and
compile it and stuff. It's often worked.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. So we'll add a clear button. The first
thing we'll do is, actually, add the clear
button in the markup. Right?
You web programmers, totally easy. Button
inside of a form. Not hard. Then we'll wire
up the onclick event on that button using
JavaScript. And that will bubble through into
the view controller, which owns the NaCl module
DOM element and, actually, finally do the
post message of the clear method. And then
we'll add a handler in C++ for that. So you
see the whole process start to finish. Okay.
So let's start with here is what we've got.
So here's this whole browser stamp editor,
right?
It's arbitrary whatever. So I can make these
stamps. I can run the simulation. And it's,
you know, doing that kind of thing. So I did
all the drag events. I can change the automaton
rules. I don't know if you can see it in the
back, but it's way at the bottom of the screen.
I can change the automaton rules. And this
is a huge mess. And I can't clear this at
all. So that's why I want to add the clear
button. Let's do that right now.
So what I do is go into my favorite text editor,
and I have these little handy hooks here for
me.
First thing I'm going to do is add the clear
button. So, if everybody can see that, this
is just absolutely straightforward. Whoops.
HTML. And, again, this is totally live. So
all bets are off.
All right. So I just put a clear button in
there. It's a button that says clear. It's
not exciting. Then what I want to do is go
and wire up the onclick event. So I'm going
to do that. Let me get this a little bit bigger,
so we can see the code. There we go. Okay.
So I go into my JavaScript. And here I'm going
to say, you know, get the DOM element and
add an event listener to it. And I want to
call the clear event handler, so I better
add an implementation for that so that it
works.
Let me put that there. Okay. So here's my
clear event handler. Again, those of you who
used web programming, this is totally normal.
I just simply say stop propagating the event,
because I'm going to handle it. And I'm going
to call the clear method on my view controller
object. The view controller is not the NaCl
module yet. The view controller owns the NaCl
module. I have to, obviously, implement this
clear method in my view controller.
So I'm going to copy that and paste it into
the view controller here. Okay. And you can
see here it's calling invoke method of clear.
Okay? So now I've done all the browser stuff.
So let's see what that looks like. So, if
I go into my shell here and I'm handily in
my life stage 2, I just say scons install.
What that does is, you see, it's taken my
HTML file that I edited, my JavaScript that
I edited, and put it into my sites directory.
By the way, on this Mac, I'm running a little
Apache server. So I'm not using that simple
HTTP server. It doesn't matter what your server
is. You just have to have one. That's all.
Okay. So let's see what happens there. So
you remember the -- what it looked like before.
Oh, so that was a caching thing. Let me open
this in an incognito window. And here's my
clear button. Okay? So let me just run this
in the random mode. Now I should be able to
hit that button. Of course, it's not working.
So why?
Well, of course, I know why. But let's take
a look at -- in -- I can whip up developer
tools here and look in my JavaScript code.
Let me get rid of this, pull that down here.
I want to make sure that I'm actually getting
the event handled correctly, right?
So, if I scroll down here to my implementation
of clear, I got a whole bunch of stuff. I'll
put a break point there on my clear button
and, again, run the simulation and hit the
clear button. And, sure enough, it is hitting
it. So let me step over that and make sure
it's indeed going into invoke method and step
into that. And it seems to be wanting to call
post message with the clear method okay. So
the -- what hasn't happened yet, of course,
is the C++ isn't there yet. So there's nothing
on the other end to actually handle this clear.
So let's go ahead and add that. Whoops. Okay.
I got to keep running. Hah-hah. That's why
it wasn't working.
There is a fascinating little debugger demo.
Now, so let's go ahead and add C++. If this
is all set up right, I
can paste it in there.
What's happening here is I have an implementation
in the C++ code that will clear the buffers.
It is this, the clear method. Here's what
that looks like, where it's simply getting
the pixel buffer that I've been painting in
and it clears it. And it clears the simulation
buffers, too, right? So that's all it's doing.
And that piece of code that I pasted in there
wires it up to the clear method so that earlier
C++ code you saw that unravels all the parameter
names so on and so forth, that's going to
then call this.
So let me save that. And now if I go in here
and say scons install, you will see it is
actually running the compiler now because
it has to build C++ code. It has made new
nexes and loaded them into my site.
So let's take a look at what that looks like,
if I remember to do in an incognito window
again, let me run the simulation. Let's throw
a couple little glider guns in there. And
if I hit "clear," it indeed clears. So let's
go into stamp mode, clear, and then I can
make a couple of glider guns in here like
this and stop the sim and clear and it works.
[ Applause ]
Okay. So that was kind of a deep dive into
the whole JavaScript to C++. Okay. So we can
-- we've connected those two things. Now let's
make this go faster, okay? So what I'm going
to do is take -- because I have the entire
simulation programmed in C++, it's fairly
straightforward to just simply take that implementation
and run it on its own pthread.
The pthread is running inside of Native Client
code. And what that helps me do is get out
of the browser's UI thread.
So normally what's going on over the pepper
bridge is as you make these postMessage calls
and so on and so forth, it is all on one single
browser thread. So it puts it on the pepper
queue. But then the runtime as it wants to
paint things onto the 2D canvas that's shared
with the browser, it has to do that on the
browser's thread. So it has to actually stop
the browser momentarily while it paints and
come back, okay?
So what we're going to do is actually separate
those two out on to separate threads and see
what happens. And this is -- so the promise
is that if you get this kind of UI snappiness,
right, in your application, that's what you
want.
So I'm going to be working entirely in the
Native Client code. There is going to be -- no
front-end programming is required for this
because all the wiring has already been done.
And all I need to do now is just have a separate
thread that runs the simulation.
Here, this is what I do some pthread create.
So client programmers, normal, right? Stuff
you're used to.
Here is where I'm shutting the module down.
I just simply join the thread and we have
mutices. And because it is just the full pthread
API and I'm programming in C code, I'm free
to do things like make condition locks, right?
So these are the kinds of things that are
not generally available in worker threads
in JavaScript. This is the full threading
with mutices, with locks, with all that kind
of stuff so you can program points of synchronization
in while the thread is running. It is not
just start up and, well, it does what it does
and you don't hear from it again.
This is -- You can do the full synchronization.
I did a little kind of seat-of-the-pants measuring.
I'm getting about 6x performance improvement
just by having one more thread. So it is quite
remarkable.
Okay. So let's see what that looks like. Actually,
what I should be able to do is -- Let me go
here. And if I reload -- Okay.
I'm going to put these side by side. Let me
see if that will work. I like to live on the
edge.
Okay. So here we have the old one. This is
the single-threaded version, and here is the
multi-threaded version. So single-threaded,
multi-threaded.
So really -- I mean, it is a remarkable difference.
And that, again, is entirely via C++ code.
There was no -- Oops! Ha, ha, ha.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Did I mention that this was live?
Okay. Let's go through the fourth stage which
is we are just going to add some multi-media
and go through what that's like. We're going
to program on the pepper bridge in C++.
So adding audio is kind of like using the
audio tag in HTML except not at all. So because
we're -- where with the audio tag you say
audio given in URL and the browser figures
out what kind of sound file you have and it
does all the decoding and all of that kind
of nice stuff, you have to do that yourself
in pepper. So that may seem daunting.
And if you all really want to do is simply
play a sound, then using the audio tag is
probably your best bet.
However, if you want to do more with it, for
example, do some processing to look at the
sound and pull speech phonoms out and then
give them time stamps so you can do lip syncing
and do that kind of processing, then this
is absolutely perfect for that.
How we do it is as an HTML5 you have an audio
tag. Here you say, We are going to have an
audio context. The way it works, it wants
a callback that is going to fill buffers.
In the C code, I have to implement -- this
is where you would do your audio processing.
This example is just simply filling buffers.
It is not doing anything fancy. And then there's
a play API that we invented that just says,
you know, run it. That's all it does. So this
really is the simple version of sound. It's,
you know, very straightforward.
What's interesting about this, though, is
that we want to decode wav files. And there's
open source code out on the Internet that
does that. So because this is Native Client
and because it's in a Sandbox and because
we have this special toolchain that does all
the security features and the validating and
everything else, I can just go and get code
from the Internet and compile it and run it.
It's not -- it doesn't have to be subject
to endless security reviews and things like
that because if the code from the Internet
is malicious, it is not going to run, right?
It will either won't pass a validator or it
will halt in the execution stage or something.
So I feel pretty confident in just getting
random code off the Internet, which is normally
an extremely unsavory thing to do. But in
this case, not a problem. Of course, I'm going
to Stanford and I'm hoping that Stanford is
kind of a respectable institution and they
produce code that's not going to do something
nasty.
But, you know, so here it is. This is all
just C code. It is very, very straightforward,
decode wav files.
The other thing I have to do is actually get
the sound resourced, right? So this is a HTTP
request, and we have pepper API to do that,
too. So I just simply say, I want to open
a request and I set it up as a Get request.
I want to follow redirects. In here, I can
also give it hints about cores and things
like that.
And then as the data comes in, I read the
response body and fill a buffer and that buffer
goes into the previous audio playback thing
you saw earlier. Just simply copies it into
the sound buffer and plays it. So it's that
straightforward.
Let's see what that looks like. Open it in
an incognito window. Let's go into stamp mode.
And if my sound is playing.
[ Beeping ]
So now -- and I cleverly got some other -- (doorbell
ringing) -- sounds in here, too. Okay. So
there it is, the fourth stage of life. All
together you can get a pretty good feel of
what we can do.
Coming attraction we are doing an interactive
debugger and integrating it with your favorite
IDE. We are starting with Visual Studio. Eventually,
we will get to other IDEs, X code, Eclipse,
et cetera, et cetera, quids, integration,
that kind of thing. But we're starting with
Visual Studio because a lot of client programmers
are already there.
We are doing things like garbage collection,
JIT support. We have a port of mono that runs
C sharp, and we are adding dynamic library
support as well. So this will reduce the size
of the binaries that you build, right?
We're doing PNaCL, which is a portable library
resource, LLVM bit code format on the wire.
That means that you only have to build one
NaCl module. The promise being that ten years
from now someone is going to invent new CPU
architecture. And we want to be able to take
nexes that exist on the Web and run them on
those two.
What's required is a translation -- kind of
the final translation stage to actual machine
code from the big code.
We're adding more HTML5 support. So, generally
speaking, we track HTML5. We're going out
the door with the 2D and the sound and some
event handling and things like that. Then
quickly followed by 3D and then peer-to-peer
and file I/O. As the HTML5 specs start to
mature and grow, we will track it.
Some attributions, of course, Conway's Game
of Life basic algorithm. Greg Wirt in the
Boulder office helped me with the graphics
and UI design. Wav format comes from Stanford.
The doorbell is from Sound Bible. Other from
wavsource, et cetera.
And where to go from here, we have a doc set.
So you can visit code.google.com/chrome/nativclient.
That gives you a full introduction to how
to program this stuff, link to get the SDK.
There is an SDK. And a reference for pepper
and there is all kinds of stuff in there,
some examples.
This life example is actually in an open source
repo right now. It is called NaCl ports. NaCl
ports contains a bunch of libraries that have
been ported to Native Client libz, tiny XML
just to name a couple. There is a bunch in
there.
Image Magic. SDL has been ported. So if you
have an SDL game, there is a NaCl port for
that.
Visit us in the Chrome Sandbox. We've got
some demos running. And if there's any feedback
for this, there's the tiny URL.
[ Applause ]
>>> Hi. Can you tell us what Google is using
this for internally, or is it in products
that we're already using?
>>David Springer: It's experimental. It is
actually -- it is an open source project.
What can I say about it?
Scientific community one, yeah, that's -- David
Kernig's thing? It runs on app? No.
We have a scientific computing project going
on within Google. That's about the only one
I know of internally.
There is a bunch of external ones. There's
-- TCL port was done. And Unity, of course,
runs on it. Yeah. SDL port was done.
>>> One of the reasons to use NaCl is efficient
usage for SMID instructions. I noticed that
in your manifest, there are only CPU architecture
and each of those features several set of
SMID. So how do you handle this?
>>David Springer: That manifest file didn't
have absolutely every switch in it. And we're
still kind of working out some of those issues.
Yeah. But that's an excellent point.
Let me take one from the back.
>>> When you were talking about GPU access,
were you talking about actual access to hardware
restorizers?
>>David Springer: No, it is more open GLES2.
>>> No, I mean like a hardware card as opposed
to software restorizer.
>>David Springer: Yes, absolutely, yes.
>>> So historically, typically we have an
elevated group privilege for direct rendering
simply because somebody will find out some
way to either gain knowledge they shouldn't
have of the system or to make some kind of
attack using the hardware. And especially
in closed source drivers, it has been a very
big problem.
So what precautions are you taking to try
and mitigate this in NaCl?
>>David Springer: We're tracking exactly what
WebGL does to solve the same problem.
>>> I should warn you that that's not enough
to keep people from potentially gaining information
about other processes that are also direct
rendering to the same GPU.
>>David Springer: Please get on our discussion
list and make your opinions known.
>>> Get on ours. Mesadev and dridevel@freedesktop.org.
>>David Springer: Thanks.
>>> Thank you.
>>> Are there any performance hits when running
your native code through the Sandbox that
you've noticed?
>>David Springer: Yes, there are. We are generally
running between 5 and 10% hit. That's a very
broad brush. There are cases -- there's degenerate
cases where it actually goes faster.
But, you know, yes, there is a performance
hit.
Back?
>>> So you mentioned that in the Sandbox environment,
of course, you can't access the FileSystem
directly. Java virtual machines with signed
applets are able to do this still today. And
there certainly are some use cases where this
is beneficial. For example, developing a Web-based
video editor, some sort of video manipulation,
you don't want to transfer all of that data
up to a server and then back down again.
Is there any kind of strategy that be used
for Native Client that you are aware of to
sort accomplish that goal of accessing that
local resource without having to transfer
it up to the server?
>>David Springer: We will track the HTML5
file I/O APIs and implement that within pepper.
So the level of access that gives you is a
level of access we'll give you in Native Client.
>>> Thank you.
>>David Springer: Okay. Front.
>>> So from the JavaScript side, that 2D canvas
you were drawing on from NaCl, is that data
readable, writable from JavaScript like we
can do with a 2D canvas? Like getting the
raw bites and reading and writing them as
well from JavaScript?
>>David Springer: We're working on that.
>>> So it would be like actually another communication
channel kind of between the NaCl side and
the JavaScript side, reading, writing data
in bitmap, mmap, bitmap?
>>David Springer: Correct.
>>> Okay, cool.
>>David Springer: Next?
>>> So is the idea to move everything eventually
to portable NaCl? And when you do that, what
sort of performance hit will you take additionally
if you move to the portable version?
>>David Springer: I don't have an answer for
that.
>>> Okay.
>>David Springer: Yeah. Sorry. Next?
>>> Is there support for Native Sockets?
>>David Springer: No, we will support the
same level as WebSockets support in terms
of actually opening Sockets.
>>> Okay, so, basically, not for traffic.
We have to go through the Web layer, not through
the native code.
>>David Springer: Right.
>>> Thank you.
>>David Springer: Okay.
>>> It might be a silly question, I'm just
wondering, you say it is an open source project.
Obviously, it will be in Chrome. Can we -- has
there been any interest from other projects
like Mozilla to actually get this into other
browsers? Is that something that's going to
potentially happen?
Or as an app dev, I'm wondering if I'm only
going to be able to target Chrome users, basically.
>>David Springer: I -- you know, we haven't
really heard anything. They're absolutely
welcome to pick up the code base and make
a runtime that works in those browsers. I
can't speak for Mozilla and those people.
>>> All right. Thank you.
>>David Springer: Sure.
All right. Thank you all for coming.
[ Applause ]